we must wage what I have called total  war against public enemy number one in  the United States the problem of  dangerous drugs every day it goes on  means more innocent people being hurt it  means wasting 50 to 100 billion dollars  a year a half of what we spend on law  enforcement the courts and the prisons  is drug-related you can buy almost any  illegal drug any city in this country  almost any neighborhood in this country  24/7 the war on drugs has been a failure  when I look at Mexico today it's like  Chicago during the days of Al Capone  times 50 50,000 people have been  murdered they haven't made a dent since  Nixon made marijuana Schedule one drug  in 1970 they're never going to make a  dent this is a colossal failure I want  the President to know that he is not  treating all of his citizens with the  love and care that he promised them am I  willing to pursue a decriminalization  strategy as an approach No  [Music]  [Music]  you